hey guys we are back with another
episode of the swish Woodland podcast
which is of course proudly brought to
you by our major sponsor Swish and swish
they are doing some amazing things in
this world having donated over 600 000
to various local charities in the past
two years as every swish purchase swish
donate up to 70 of the proceeds to
charity so how good and if you haven't
checked out their website yet
heyswish.com I highly recommend you jump
on scroll through the list of sporting
Legends on there and there is plenty to
choose from Prices range from 300 down
to just twenty dollars and remember when
you order add the promo code what a lad
for a discount it also makes a great
birthday present for any sports lover
out there and if you're Keen to get one
I'll leave a link in the description
below so just go click on that also if
you're suffering from any muscle or
joint pain or you're just struggling to
sleep at night then pure sport is what
you need in your life I'm always getting
messages from listeners who have felt
the massive benefits from their products
and if you're a live eye on
anti-inflammatories or painkillers
regularly I strongly suggest you pack
those and give this a go there's no
issues getting it into New Zealand and
it is the most tested and trusted CBD
oil in the world and just for being a
well-led listener you can get 20 off
your order by using the code waterlad20
I'll leave a link in the description
below to go check it out and last but
not least Regan Todd from Todd's racing
is training winners for fun at the
moment and that list of winners will
hopefully grow as our very own Waterland
horse hits the track you can join the
Journey of Woodland by becoming an owner
for as little as 1K or if you just want
to follow the journey head over to
Todd's racing on Facebook and give them
a follow if you're interested in the
horse give me a DM on Instagram and I'll
send you the details but let's get to
the show
absolute
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah what a lead well if you've played
rugby in New Zealand in the last decade
it is more than likely that you've
either played with or against today's
guest he is the ultimate journeyman who
has more sets of Team kit than any other
player I know this guy has played or
trained with basically every NPC and
super team in the country and just last
year he was rewarded with his Super
Rugby debut for Moana Pacifica he's also
been a regular New Zealand Maori side
and he's currently starring for the
natipuro east coast and the Heartland
comp he's the ultimate battle and the
ultimate lead it is the great Joey Royal
welcome mate cheers mate again what an
intro
you're my first guest to have his very
own uh mic so mate you're you're coming
through these Airways very nice you're
right on I thought you know when I got
the message I thought you know better
get in the wardrobe pull the mic out put
it to use
you know it's been been a while I love
it I love it and like I said you are
sounding very good but I always get
heaps of requests to get um guys on the
Heartland comp on so mate you're sort of
the perfect fit playing Heartland but
you've also played every level with the
Resin Rugby test rugby with the New
Zealand maoris and a fair amount of Club
rugby as well
I think I'm like the
traveling Gypsy of New Zealand rugby
most most provinces in
a Wardrobe full of Team kit yeah what's
your favorite kit you must have you must
have a massive stash do you keep it all
right I've kept a few jerseys but
wardrobe and drawers get raided
um you know when finally come and visit
so yeah I don't really have too much kit
left I've got all my jerseys though but
no uh no playing kit and East Coast uh
semi-final this weekend hell of a season
from from the guys up there how did that
opportunity to play for them come about
uh well this yeah this is um was meant
to be sort of the retiring year
finishing you know looking at what's
next in this journey but uh Jose sort of
messaged at the start of the
seeing what my plans were and I said oh
look I'm still playing Club I still want
to have a crack at counties and then um
pretty cliche when one door closes
another opens yeah
yeah when that uh NPC door closed uh
took the opportunity of messaging hoes
back and said
I'll come down if you have me bro
and how's it been loving it is yeah yeah
loving it's just a I tell the boys that
yeah it's
you have appreciation for that Heartland
level if you haven't been down there or
if you don't know about it you sort of
people can look down on that comp and be
like ah you know it's just the level
above Club bar and there's some teams
down there that could probably push some
you know push some of the NPC sites
especially you know South Canterbury we
played them last week and
we we pushed them for a bit but there
are they're a decent outfit down there
I'd note they feed the boys
downtown Canterbury yeah those South
Canterbury boys are massive yeah
right but you guys are you guys have had
a pretty successful uh season obviously
a couple of big games to go how's your
form been
oh it's been uh it's been good like we I
think we've exceeded expectations of
sort of with the goals that Jose and the
CEO are sitting at the start of the year
so
to make a semi's pretty pretty special
because a lot of those guys were part of
their run where they lost eight years in
a row or something
so for them to get to this stage there
so they're buzzing there's a bit of a
buzz through Little Tortilla up the
coast yeah my form oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah I had a bad form against West Coast
to be honest uh terrible game not got
dropped the next week
right but east coast is a team which I
mean you spoke about the community they
do get right behind that side eh and
it's uh it's pretty pure rugby up there
when uh when you watch it on the TV I've
never actually been there myself but
everyone who's spoken about it talks
about how special it is you know with
the horses and just the vibe that the
community bring to the game so being a
part of it as it has it been like that
yeah it's
um it's been a I think a breath of fresh
air sort of a new lease on life I guess
because like I said I was going to
retire this year and sort of wasn't
keen on plane and you're going down a
sort of yeah sort of give him this old
body of sort of
a new leasing be like yeah you can do it
again come on let's go Joey what team
next
um
the the community down there like they
Becky hard but they you do something
wrong man they come down on you like a
ton of brexit
like my my first game that was like a
big opener because because I'm I'm
considered a loan player yeah
and um like we're losing yeah we just
had a terrible game as a team but
man those locals there are brutals I I
got subbed off and I was like walking
down the goal line
um and as I was walking I could hear the
fans be like
get those effing lone players off the
locals are and I was like oh they cut me
these but as soon as I sort of got to
their end and walked past them they're
like ah too much Joe we're all thanks
for coming down brother I was like what
have I got myself into
so after that weekend I should try to
make a big effort to
um yeah get to know the the locals in
yeah try and put a put a bit of Mana
back in in myself and the performance
that I put out there in that first game
so all right that's good keep you on
your toes yes no doubt you've done that
but you you did mention
um your age and I what 37 now how is the
body feeling
yeah not too bad eh to be honest I think
as you get older you sort of your
training changes to to suit the way you
own I'm not they'll bouncy 19 to a new
year old that you see now and some of
the layers that you've had on your
podcast and
these young ones just go hard at
training but I kind of know what what I
need to do to be ready and keep myself
yes relatively fit to play but who knows
might go again next year oh there he is
we'll see how we go we'll see how we go
but anyway Matt I know you're you're a
regular listener of the podcast so you
know the drill let's let's start from
the start give us the rundown of your
childhood
wow um
into a lot of my uh younger schooling
years there so all the way to primary
uh just just your regular Saturday footy
with mates and cousins
um Barefoot I don't think too many of
your uh guests would have been Barefoot
on frosty mornings
uh yeah these days they get to wear
boots in your five so
and then we moved to taupo and I think
that was my first Rec team was the king
country roller mills I think had to be
like under 55 kgs
uh so being a 65 kg
year eight was uh was a bit tough to try
and shed 10 kgs but it worked and sort
of yeah made made King country and then
how did you shoot the 10 kgs that's a
decent effort right the coach at the
time
uh
she made me move in with him and his
family oh yeah
yeah like told me to like move out of my
heart I was
12 maybe yeah
um so I lived with him for like two
weeks I hated it it
um his son was in the team with me
and he'd make us
um like stoke the lounge fire up
so it was like it felt like 100 degrees
and would be sitting on the bike with
rubbish beef
like biking at nine o'clock at night
and then straight to bed get up and then
it would be like those little rice
crackers for breakfast rice crackers for
lunch
um get home and it's a banana and rice
cracker and they're back on the bike
sure but it was honestly brutal but I
got got to the 10 kgs got the weigh-in
at the tournament and then just picked
up after that
but it must have been pretty good for
the coach to put you through that sort
of intense regime to get you to play I
don't know it's I think it was you know
the you know how you get those kids
where
you're just bigger than everyone else
yeah yeah I think I was that kid yeah
and they just probably naturally thought
yeah this guy would be good at rugby
Steamroller bigger kid yeah he's a the
bigger kid trying to just get picked on
size really and what position were you
were you always a front rower no that
was a number eight oh yeah well they put
me they put me at eight
and then I met my best mate he we're
still good mates now we ended up being
second five Center
sort of experience it was pretty cool it
was
we've got to hide in there like the
Auckland schools smacked us yeah
um I don't think we won the game but
it was fun yeah and did you love rugby
was like what was what was your goals in
rugby did you just love it so much that
you always wanted to keep playing it
because I mean I looked through your
your journey and I think
there must have been points throughout
your career where you must have thought
why am I doing this or things like that
so what was your sort of motivation to
play the game uh I think at the younger
age was just just to play
uh with my mates on a weekend and
actually we had a few um I had a few
Rich Pacquiao mates in it and my teams
growing up so it was a good opportunity
to
hey befriend him and then go to their
houses on the weekends after footing
and play with all these toys
and right there like bikes and
motorbikes and that so
um that was a good motivator but
uh I never I never had an upbringing of
waking up early to watch footy yeah
um yeah all black tests in it I've got a
taste of all sports but early memories
are just just watching my dad play
really
um and then hearing his stories
um it wasn't until I went to college
that sort of I thought you know try and
make a career of it if I can so what
what changed that college for you to
make you think that I just
because I went to theater College
um which is back in the days was a
pretty
it was renowned for there for their
footy like their
um
quite well known in New Zealand circles
for for being pretty pretty good and
just hearing the history and in all the
players that had gone through there and
then just how much
the emphasis they put into all the teams
that at the time were sort of just like
oh yeah Super Rugby was playing on the
weekends
just been I think around
uh rugby minded uh boys as well
just to help push you through and and
keep you motivated to make rip teams up
there and then post school like uh a lot
of kids these days uh it probably drives
me nuts but most kids walk out of school
with contracts lay down in front of them
um you your pathway was a bit different
I know you went into the Auckland club
scene I think you battled it out for
maybe six or seven years
um before an opportunity came so how
hard was that and was there a point
during that where you thought
maybe it's not going to happen you're
not going to be a professional rugby
player yes uh I guess post School
and I moved I moved actually moved to
Wellington and like then
uh or the rugby scene down there was all
the older guys like he said like young
guys now walking into Super teams buddy
millionaires
um
you know back then you did have to
battle and you're actually battling
against like old guys or older older
guys and actually mature you know tough
dude so yeah it's yeah good on them
these days for young guys so okay to get
that opportunity and
I said yeah my my journey was a bit a
little bit different and um to be honest
if I had listened to some advice back
when I was a bit younger I could have
made it a bit earlier to be honest yeah
but um
you did better it out a bit up here and
I think there was one situation I was at
work I won't name the
organization they'd probably be
listening
I was working yeah working at this place
and we were just watching some rugby on
TV and I kind of just mentioned it be
like oh yeah man I'm pretty Keen to make
that make it over there one day nothing
was like 20
25. even 24 at this at that time
and um and my mate my workmate turned
around to me and just said I'm 82 old
mate just give up you're not gonna make
it yeah like straight away in in my head
I was like you know what [ __ ] you mate
I'm gonna show you yeah got on the
blower too
ah
that's like half-assed agent that I had
and it um
he uh he gave me the number to Kevin
Schuler down at the vein he's like I
ring this guy's like hey isn't this your
job
he's like oh now they're expecting the
call from you so I rang him and Kim was
like oh hey mate who's this
he's like
who oh General from walking my agent
told me to ring he was like
oh nice to meet you it's like the most
awkward conversation
and he was like what are you ringing for
I was like oh uh I heard there was an
opportunity down the bay and then he was
like oh we are looking but you'd have to
move down here and see how you go so I
was like all right sweet uh sort of sat
down with my partner or cows at the time
to
talk about it she wasn't too Keen but
yeah I moved to move to Vegas I moved
actually moved them with him mum sure
just to stay down there and yeah had a
crack and
yeah uh the rest is history so you
weren't offered a contract from Bad
Planet it was just an opportunity to
play Club footy and try and earn one
yeah
yeah and it was like the second half of
the Club season so I'd already played
the first half up here yeah and yeah my
mate or my workmate said what he said
and I was like you know [ __ ] it this is
gay here we go and I went down for the
second half of the Season actually got
injured the first game blew my cuff had
a small tear and my first game for
rotuity and then um I sort of had a week
off and I was like
I just need to play just so I can be
seen so I played with a like a minor
tear in my calf for the rest of the
season
um
got wrapped in the face I was out for
another week uh and then I think they
must have just thought oh
he's a bad language just give him
something he's done enough he's done
enough he's yeah
um but that that season there had
actually worked out to be a sort of
uh a defined amount like Nate Harris
heals them he was the starter yeah for
us and then he got injured in our last
preseason game oh yeah
um in the united managed to jump and
start for like the first five games yeah
good and you obviously went pretty good
ah the first two games are good score to
try on debut and
um yeah some of the boys who got on
there at the tip
I think I was paying like eight bucks I
think to screw a try yeah the days when
hookers weren't scoring more than
Wingers
so post that by plenty season is this
where you got looks in with the Chiefs
and the hurricanes with the wider squads
yeah so
after that base season I actually got a
call from Colin Coop Coots to say that I
was in the picture for the maoris what
was that phone call like I I actually
thought it was a prank yeah
because because we knew the squads were
coming out and um
at the time like oh if you know Joe 2p
and umani they're like Jokers they were
jokers are the team and I actually
thought it was them calling yeah so I
was just saying oh yeah so hey Hey Joe
it's Coop's here
I should know because um you know
you know bloody I met him uh when I was
living in Wellington and uh yeah he was
just saying oh you're in the frame for
for the maoris just just keep fit
because we're
but the Steamers we're at a finals
contention then and I moved back to
Auckland to just blow up really and then
um yeah cubes was like oh just stay stay
in shape uh we are looking at you and
then I hadn't heard for like maybe until
the day of when they named the team and
tabs
uh called me and said um
yeah congratulations you're in we're
going to name you in the Maori Squad uh
this afternoon and uh yeah that was that
was Buzzy is I was at home and
um my dad was just about to leave to go
to work
and actually cows had left for work and
I was on the phone to her and I said and
then the phone call came through and I
said oh [ __ ] someone's calling I'll ring
you back it was tabs caught her back
told her that I was off and made the
team and
she was crying I could hear workmates at
work asking if she was okay and yeah
I told my dad and my dad's not a
emotional guy but he I think that sort
of hit him I told that I'd made it
pretty it's pretty Buzzy pretty crazy
hey like you were grinding away for six
seven years like we spoke about in the
Auckland club scene didn't really look
like much was going to happen and then
opportunity comes you back yourself to
go to back Lenny you get a little bit
fortunate with an injury to Nate Harris
like you mentioned then take your
opportunity and then you've gone from
being you know like a club player to a
test player with New Zealand maoris in
the space of a season it's pretty pretty
crazy you know you pinch yourself now
every time you talk about it because
right um
actually named like Corey Flynn Deco and
hecka
oh sorry Deco wasn't even in it it was
me flenny and hika sure and then Corey
got injured and Deco came into
just even that story with Deco not even
being in the picture and in what he last
six years and captains the team yeah
just those little Connections in
and then that team there's like pity
Jared Andre Taylor they was like that
was like a mean team to be a part of in
rubber shoulders with those guys to
learn off Timmy Bateman was in there so
all the lads did you feel like you
belonged in there obviously you'd had
your your rise had happened pretty quick
did you feel like you're good enough to
be in that in that team
initially no because I like I said you
you're in an international team but with
like Superstars that you watched yeah
um not growing up because I was probably
older than half of them
but you know like watching watching
those boys on TV grinded out for years
and then yeah you have only had like six
months of footy and then you're playing
with them as I I do I actually belong
here but it wasn't until we went away on
tour and then got the train with them
and once we got into it you'd be like
yeah this is me I'm gonna you know do
everything I can to try and stay here as
long as I can because
it doesn't last long uh you just try to
soak in as much as I could and
and try and
submit a spot in there as as you know as
long as I could
which you did to be fair didn't you like
even though you weren't making
um the Super Rugby size or getting many
opportunities at Super level you you're
a pretty consistent name in that New
Zealand oldest side over the over the
years eh yes I think it was just
fortunate that yeah that I could sort of
cover
cover a couple of positions in
um maybe done enough to in the trust of
like Coupes in in the other coaches that
yeah to keep picking me and they're just
super grateful for that
yeah never never took any of those
um opportunities for granted so
yeah pretty pretty amazing to be a part
of it and
yeah I'll be that old guy sitting at the
bar always talking about those days you
know
that's it and what what other positions
could you cover was it eight and twelve
like the old days oh man
how could they I actually asked who's if
I could play 12 one day for East Coast
but yeah
um no I I covered uh Lucid Pro and it
out of push tidy but true
um yeah it sort of just covered all
three
but mainly mainly at Hooker and in could
go across the Lucid that's pretty
impressive yeah I think 20 props in New
Zealand will have to go down it tidy for
me to go
four and a half but then uh we spoke
about your sort of intro into the Super
Rugby
um scene so it must was it posters New
Zealand Maori selection where obviously
super teams will be thinking uh jeez
this guy's not even in a super squad
he's playing New Zealand maltes why has
no one got him
well it actually turned out uh it while
we're in the states my agent called me
and said oh too long I need a
replacement hooker oh yeah are you Keen
to go and I said yeah I'll be Keen
and then herb oh Kevin shorter got
caught wind of it and then
sort of got on the blower to Dave Rennie
and the Chiefs and said ah
we don't want Joe to go because
the money would be good enough that he
won't come back and we want him back for
the base season but I had like I'm a man
on my word if I said I'll come back I'll
come back and it was yeah it was good
money
um just for that short stint and so on
but um somehow the the Chiefs got me to
come down for the preseason
uh because their stage hooker had that
serious injury yeah uh after the first
game in in the state so they needed
someone to replace him
and again it was out of me and Nate
again
um that pre-season and
yeah just got put through the ringer and
that pre-Christmas
um preseason with the Chiefs and the
last day they we had our reviews and
it was actually funny because the
trainers
um
we have a laugh about it now and at the
trainers at the time they they said oh
look Joe man you've come a long way
you've yeah
to be honest when Dave Rennie and it
told us that you were coming in for
pre-season we wondered why you they
picked you
because you're you're an overweight
hooker uh
and you know we we knew you won't be
ready for Super Rugby but you definitely
proved us wrong in these three weeks and
um you know you're one of the fittest
now and
but unfortunately we're going to go with
Nate
cool man cool review
um
and then they're like
they said oh we're playing Cricket
tomorrow you can come to that last day
if you want to I was like if I did I'm
not going I'm gonna go back to Rotorua
see my family I don't hang around and
play cricket if I'm not coming back
after news
was wait something that you always
struggled with yeah oh you know
I could like you said in those
years leading up to you know
professional rugby I had no trainers I
had no nutritionists yeah
I was just going off
um what I knew at Club rugby and go
there around Henny mullers and around
bloody shuttles that's how I thought it
was getting fit and strong yeah so I
never had a sense of you know what
a super rugby player should be like
so that was my first exposure was that
the Chiefs and then it was
pretty much the next day when I left the
Chiefs wardy ring and asked the fonzer
to come down
to you guys down at the canes because um
Deco was having surgery or something
yeah
had to get something done and I I don't
know why but
when he asked me I was like oh can I
call you back I just got to ask my
missus
I don't know why I said that and then I
went I said ah hey babe um the king's
this ring and asked if I could go down
after news she was like if and ring them
back man say that you're going I was
like oh okay okay
so yeah I should have just said yes
straight away Woody but I don't know
survival instincts kicked in and thought
oh [ __ ] it asked them headset priorities
so then what was it like going down to
the canes obviously pretty quick
turnaround like going straight from the
cheese to the canes how did it compare
all right um
I actually loved it down there but you
guys thought it came to Roman and cheese
all super environments are different
and um
it was hard for me at the Chiefs because
I didn't know
too many people when I came down to the
canes a new deco
Timmy Bateman was there he knew
everywhere yeah I sort of knew because
all the Maori boys were there
I don't know you guys uh the canes of
Rome or you guys are sort of uh maybe a
lot more inviting than when I came in
which made it easier to transition down
the end yeah some some crack up stories
of my time down there it was actually
funny give ourselves give us uh I just
remember at the end of the year
like I think you guys it
we just missed out on the series or
something and I was in Rotorua and I was
getting like voice messages and video
calls to like come down to Wellies I was
like
well I've got no money I can't fly down
I think the boys even rallied together
to like a donation box to buy me a
ticket to get down here
I didn't take it but yeah the the stuff
that was coming through was pretty
pretty awesome I think if boys were at
the cricket then they ended up on a boat
somewhere and I was yeah
big fomo
sitting in my lounge room watching but
yeah just just good times and I learned
pretty fast that uh how brutal or how
physical
the canes can be and Desi my first intro
into the run at Street challenges
[Music]
um I don't know if you remember the the
cage I think that was the first year for
the case yeah at the top
yeah it was his it was his drill so we
all went up to the cage and he was like
I was split into two groups and then
I sort of just hang with the guys that I
was training with
um
and I we didn't know what the drill was
and then
there was that drill where uh you had to
one guy was in the middle of the square
and you had like six guys just in front
of you and you had to spread back to
okay and come back and make a tackle
yeah
in um our group had like John swallger
fafili avavi
um
Jack lamb
like all the Heavy Hitters
Richie goodies was in there
and then the other group were like all
the backs classified Davido
are we at Chris Smiley too he stepped up
and came in our group but the the drill
started and in one group like the backs
group they were like putting a bit of
footwork on just doing nice easy chops
and then I turned around to our group
they're like yelling Samoan swear words
at each other and they're just running
it straight and I'm like
uh actually Johnny Johnny grab me okay
just head down and just
yeah just go hard right because if you
if you put footwork on these boys will
like break you I was like
okay yeah
and I was yeah everyone knows that
I was like
like so when the boys will go and I was
like the next in line and I'll be like
I see it now that's
just I'll try and catch him as he's
coming back so he's going to the cane
yeah
the boy's mindset was wait till they get
back and then go yeah I was like now in
fact there I'm gonna catch him as he's
coming back
um
yeah so that was uh that was a tough
draw I think normally like nearly broke
his ankle in that one
and that drawing that that's how I
actually got to stay a little bit longer
sure because yeah I actually said I was
gonna play for free I mean he got
injured too no that's that's the one
thing I remember I always remembered
that like um I remember when your time
was up and you go up to the up to the
boss's office and have the yarn say that
ask if you can stay on and stay for free
and always remember that because I was
like man this guy this guy obviously
loves her he he's Keen to get an
opportunity and the fact that you're
willing to stay on for free showed you
just sort of how much you were loving it
down there and how much you love the
game
yes so I think we just finished playing
the blues yeah pre-season we went all
right we went pretty good I think we won
and then the next week I was going to
start against the rebel and then yeah it
was just as I was running out
um hammer came over and
it's out of our hands we can't take you
because New Zealand Rugby has come and
see it that we need to use one of the
other props we want to use you
and that was that was pretty gutting you
know like you get told you're going to
start that last pre-season and then
possibly stay on for longer
and then um yeah I just I again rang the
misses and said Allah I'm not going to
Melbourne now I have to come home
because the new son he's a stupid New
Zealand Rugby Rule and this is she it
was actually here that mentioned she
goes well why don't you just stay down
there I was like oh yeah sweet went
straight up to the
Hammer see hammer and what engine said
oh look I'll just
I'll just stay trained for free just
give me a job of old tipuni see if the
pro will hook me up with the job
I'll go and play Club down here and yeah
I think yeah I'll just see so Keen to
stay within the environment and and help
push the boys even though if I wasn't
playing but you couldn't do it because
of the nzru rule was that yes some NZ
are you rule that you couldn't uh a
franchise couldn't hold
another player if they had a
certain amount of props though oh yeah
like they had to use some another prop
uh for for Reggie and I had to wait for
another prop to get injured to come back
yeah
um the hookers were a bit different
because you can only have three in the
squad but if one of them go down you can
go and I think all squads carry an extra
prop so
yeah I was you're pretty gutted about
that one but it went back to Rotorua and
just yeah got back into Club in in
another base season so after like after
you sniff with the Super Rugby squads
obviously got a pre-season and you're
with the canes most of the Season what
sort of stopped you from that next year
you know being picked in a squad
um I think at the time the all the super
squads had cemented like like all their
all their players and because there was
a whole bunch of young guys coming
through so yeah
um you know like Cody Cody's with the
through with the Crusaders and I think I
had gone to the Landers and then they've
opened up a spot for like
honestly I'm more about I think he was a
bit after uh but there was here there
was no spots at the canes I'd actually
tried to negotiate something by myself
a full camera left yeah to try and get
on that that next year but yeah I think
the board waited till the new coaches
came through to see who who they had
yeah I think all super squads are
already all signed up for
for those years so that I couldn't get
in yeah did you always find that if it
was a 50 50 decision it would always be
teams would always go if the younger guy
you see it quite a bit you know there's
a 25 year old or a 18 year old or 19
year old they'll generally go that 19
year old just expect to get a little bit
more out of them or yeah and I think
that's there was really my age sort of
played a factor throughout my career
especially at the next level in my head
I'm like yeah
just go with go with the best but or not
the best but go of
maybe the experience over overuse and
just give those youth a bit of time to
especially as a front row yeah
you don't really see the front rows get
to the peak to about you know there 37
mid-20s yeah
any super teams out there
he's ready
oh he's ready always ready and then
obviously the next move was to the
Steelers wasn't it from the bay yeah
why'd you move up there was that just to
get back home
uh yeah those those that was one of the
reasons just to get back but yeah I
think my time my time ran out down there
you know the the staff at the time
we're looking at a different direction
and
yeah I thought I good opportunity to get
home
um my contract had run out down there
so I was on two years after
yeah I was on a 2-2
um contract after my first year and then
um
he's just sort of decided there good
good to give back and then
uh I was actually just going to work and
then uh tuna ring because he was on our
maoris tour oh yeah 2016. so he he rang
saying James Parsons was going to be out
for but
and if I wanted to come train with the
Blues
he took that opportunity and I was
actually going to try and stay in
Auckland and play play here
but the antenna was like nah we're gonna
go out to counties if you're going to
play for the blues I was like oh okay
two days
yes sir
let's see that's how I ended up there
actually Augustine Germany Tupa and uh
poliasimanu got into the coaches at the
time and said that you need to get on
and sign Joe raw uh we need a hooker and
he's with us at the blue so
get him there did you ever get
frustrated that you weren't ever getting
an opportunity at Super liver obviously
you'd been in uh training for a bit and
then
um never really got that opportunity to
make your day boo yeah later later in my
my at early in the career I wasn't too
fast yeah yeah just grateful and it is I
got a bit on and got a few NPC caps on
the under the belt I thought yeah why
and why not
get in the crack
um yeah I'm doing the hard yards I'm
I'm doing just as much as the other
hookers but yeah I don't know didn't
really know what was going on in the
feed feedback from coaches are like are
you doing a great job just keep it up
you know
standard
um feedback you know comments
thank you what do I need to do with it
just carry on yeah I'm not getting
picked so what what do I need to do so
yeah yeah a little bit of frustration
just kicked in a bit did you ever think
about giving up on the on the dream or
no I was uh after the 2017
blue season I thought no that's it if I
haven't if I haven't had a game now I'm
not going to get picked up check the
play so how old were you then
30
32 32 oh yeah yeah so I thought oh yeah
32 not many hookers are getting getting
a crack at Super at this age
um and then then the focus turned to uh
how long can I play NPC for
um so yeah and then just
pushed hard for for the Steelers
um for them I put all my energy and to
the those following Seasons into the
Steelers and and Club footy and then and
then the opportunity to get your first
Super Rugby cap
um 2022 what have you must have been now
34 sex with your 36. probably you
weren't training with Moana at all were
you talk me through this one all right I
was not training at all
I was not training at all
I I just actually I just signed up at
one of the gyms down the road
um called Dan Kirkpatrick's gym oh yeah
so I was just here just betting in a way
in the classes not really doing much and
then
not in my head I'm thinking yeah I'm fat
um and then I get a like a random text
from poliasi money because I knew he was
with the team yeah and all it said was
dockle stay ready so I was like what
I sort of gonna take note of it and then
Kevin Senior rangan
he was like ah hey Joey uh we are
looking we're looking for hookah because
all our all our hookers I got covered
they've gone down and we need uh we're
playing the Blues
a couple of days yeah
I think they played them on a Tuesday
kiwi rang me Saturday night oh yeah and
he just said oh you're in the frame I
said oh all good and then never thought
much of it'll be like yeah whatever I
probably got a young hook or somewhere
yeah
and it wasn't until I mean bulls rang me
uh philosophy around me
yeah good mate
have you been training are you fit
yeah of course
yeah for this he goes would you last 80
minutes I was like of course I'll ask 80
minutes any day I'll go hard
anyways I could I'll ring you back
and then didn't hear anything until
Monday night and they said all right
you're in the team it's true we played
Tuesday oh wow yeah you weren't starting
though you're on the bench hey now it's
on the beach yeah watch for you again
grateful
I haven't trained they haven't seen you
I haven't met the boys I don't know
who's in the team they're probably not
going to put me on
um yes I met I met the team
at four o'clock that day on Monday
Tuesday on Tuesday game day holy yeah
nothing not fair I didn't even do
Captain's run
um but he met them at the stadium
and as the boys are getting ready we did
like a walk throughout on the field
um I don't know any cause didn't any
moves or any systems I
sort of yeah rugby instincts just kicked
in what about the lie down watch
um the two lines that are through
I just told uh Michael Curry that I was
going to throw it to him oh yeah before
I said just just walk in and I'll just
throw you I'll just throw it to you yeah
yeah excuse me
they're both backboards as well so oh
he was like oh let's we'll just throw it
to the friend I was like nah it's there
just walking at the back and I'll hit
you
yeah sweet grateful it wasn't overthrown
or strong
oh right this yarn would be real
terrible
oh that was crazy but then was that it
like did you stand with the squad or was
that just you ran for a day and then uh
get your day pack
she stayed in full
yeah yeah so uh stayed in for that game
I played that game and then uh warmed up
on the Saturday all right boys
because there were a couple of nuclear
injuries
and then I was out for one week and then
got brought back in
before the
the train Tasman sort of setup yeah
um and then there in and out sort of
like a maybe a week on week off
for the rest of the year it's so good
yeah what was that environment like what
was what was the Moana Pacifica like
like looks like they've got a really
cool culture they sort of look like they
developed that pretty quickly last year
so what was it like to be involved in it
he also made like again
new team but everyone's on the same
everyone's on the same level yeah so
they all have I don't know I think
that's what made the culture so good is
it
yeah they all had sort of similar or
something in common that they can all
relate to and you know there'll be a
Powerhouse in the next couple years I
reckon like give them time to the jail
and that professional
environment
and be on the same level as all the
other super teams but
you know 8K results went too flash for
some games but yeah like I said they're
going to be a Powerhouse
um in the next couple few years I reckon
or even a couple years and you're not
involved this year not yet you're just
waiting covering as usual yeah just
ready stand ready yeah I had a I had a I
had a wee chat with uh Aaron yeah
about about other stuff let's say
something else but um
he just said stay really Stay Ready
brother you know you never know
famous words
so yeah so post East Coast season what
what is your what does it look like for
you when you say stay ready do you are
you training pretty hard or do you sort
of just cruise for a bit and then when
the opportunity comes
you're sort of scrambling
um I actually might stay really this
time
uh I've been roped into the CrossFit
comp with the gym that I'm at Dan's gym
uh just sort of in the team's theme so
it's gonna sort of keep me busy until
maybe November yeah
but
um I'm Keen to look into sort of the
next next phase of of 48
maybe get into some coaching yeah maybe
yeah sort of join the ranks of the up
and coming coaches uh or the next gen no
um see the likes of yourself uh Whopper
Jared as well yeah
um yeah Shane Christie all you guys are
doing some
getting some cool opportunities and
thought you know why not um
here maybe look at that now after after
footy nice mate you'll be a great coach
but what does that look like like where
do you go where do you start
yeah that's a well that's a good
question where do I start it's gonna be
a question for you
I I don't know
they've said maybe started yeah age
grade and and work your way up um I'm
not I'm not too sure really I
I gotta I guess find out where where I
put this if I'm if I can teach younger
guys or would I fit into an NPC team
straight away or I think
straight away or
yeah I'm not too sure you go straight
New Zealand oldies don't you mate they
came out mate
anyone else that's joining me you know
you want a specialist coach sing out
what would be your area
scram front row yeah probably 40 scrum
yeah yeah probably sprung to start off
of beer specialist yeah
I like I like to challenge myself and do
like maybe attack or yeah or D because
I'm not renowned for my diva it could be
a good work on you know try and
you come up with a d system that they
could work or help help other guys you
know in their in that area I don't know
right exciting it's still fresh yeah
exciting times and also a podcast day I
know you you've run a podcast before and
potentially looking to go down that
pathway you got your mic ready you're
you're halfway there yeah halfway yeah
got a decent mic here but um yeah like I
think I was when I was listening to
Grayson's one or one of the other ones
well one of your other podcasts and you
know like the likes of yourself
um you know the legend of Marty Banks
like those guys getting
the opportunities for players like
ourselves to to tell our stories I think
that's
that that's good for New Zealand to see
and I know I'd like to go down that
Avenue maybe not with
us rugby players but Branch out to like
local Legends around here uh I wanted to
do a podcast with my nan like she's seen
some things yeah up here up in Auckland
but even like you just covering all sort
of walks of life I guess and I know I've
listened to year one with um nihi and
Sean wainui which
um mate there must be a tough one to
listen back to but it was a pretty
special one at the time yeah that was
that was uh it was tough to listen back
back at it now I just listened to it
maybe a couple weeks ago yeah
um but that one down was was cool uh I
was during during our lockdown in
Auckland and everyone else was still
playing so it was good to
talk to them to see you know what uh the
comp was like without you know the three
Auckland teams in
uh we talked a bit about uh Maori
language and how that's revived in our
game now and
um how it's more accepting and then yeah
and then uh we all know sort of what
happened with Shawnee after that and
that was like a week week after that
podcast was finished
it was yeah we we heard the news about
Shawnee so yeah a little bit
sad to listen and hard to listen back on
but just uh good to good to hear his
voice again yes
uh
uh just hearing that cheekiness
um so fifth if anyone is you know out
there and then they they do want to hear
it listen it's on Spotify somewhere so
or the podcast app somewhere yeah I
think it's under top podcast sure is it
I don't know I haven't seen this
wait it's one of the greats that's only
one episode
oh but no that is exciting times ahead
for you
um as always you know you know the drill
we have gone to Instagram for some
questions plenty have come through
um obviously you've played with a lot of
players so there's a lot of people who
know you well who follow the podcast but
first question ask him why East Coast is
the best team and ask him about the
post-match feeds ah feeds are unreal
like they are a legend in themselves
those feeds like
yeah Seafood
like a shitload of seafood
um the boys get sick of you know uh well
Ken is again uh muscles again uh
crayfish again I hate you but it is the
rest of us alone
big roast meals a steam pudding custard
ice cream yeah that works right that's a
living after every match after every
home match year wow that's good stuff
okay next one what was the lava bar and
are you gutted it's gone
right if you if you don't know the lava
bar you ain't living
where was it
wow
Backpacker Barn Rotorua oh yeah
a Unreal scene unreal scene but actually
the original lava bar was probably the
best nightclub in Red River was just
this like it looked like a state home oh
yeah
yeah like I run down state home but you
go outside and it's like a spot of the
it's just a small bar and then they
renovated it to this big ass one and
here's some unreal Knights there sort of
leaving it Place being carried out and
Yeah Kells is actually a bar a bartender
there so oh is that how you met I
actually met at another club
[Laughter]
but you spend a lot of time at the lava
bar by the sounds wow yeah if cows are
working I was definitely in there
okay good stuff okay next one can we
please get better dry July jokes ah yeah
of course we can come up with some more
dried actually I want to give that a
rest because no one was laughing at the
end of it I think the first first three
days were like 200 plus likes and then
by the end of it was like one I was like
you know what I'm I'm done with these no
one's no one's enjoying them so what's
your best joke
uh
well one's it one that stuck with me for
ages like did you know cardi B has a
sister
sorry
cardio ah mate that must have been the
200 like one because that is classic
um yeah there's there's been some
terrible ones right and have you thought
about commit being a stand-up at all
no no no
definitely not
all right I gotta research these jokes
yeah just a whole heap of dry July Jacks
would be one of the great stand-up gigs
yeah
living okay next one why do you switch
teams so much
I go with them I go where people want me
have you ever been in the position where
you've had like multiple offers where
you had to make a choice or has it
always been just going wherever
obviously you turned down too long and
not many people can say they did that
but other than that yeah
um not in not not in New Zealand I've
been had a decorated career like most
guests on here we have the options to
choose which teams but
no I haven't I'm sort of I'm just taking
what's what's been presented I guess
yeah
there's generally only one option
do you regret that too long decision at
all do you ever look back and think [ __ ]
I wonder if I did play for too long I
wonder if I'd still be you know maybe be
playing for France yeah okay
I don't like to live with regrets but
yeah it's for the one
like if I if I have a regret with footy
then that's probably one of them yeah
just not taking that opportunity because
both cows and I could have traveled
like seeing that sort of and you hear
stories about what living over there is
like in
just the experience from other boys but
um yeah actually I I actually could have
been in Italy one year and I had a
clause to get out of my contract but
so I I actually signed the contract to
go to Benetton
sure uh trevisa so I had actually I
actually signed it and I was ready to go
my agent sent it away like the week
after it came vaccine uh sorry we can't
take you because we've we've got a New
Zealand Coach and he's just bought uh a
kiwi and two Aussies so I missed that on
uh overseas yeah yeah yeah yeah and one
of them was Banksy oh okay awesome you
didn't last long days
[Music]
oh true oh you could have been in Italy
yeah so that was but yeah that Leon one
was yeah
I always think about it what could have
been if I'd gone classic Ben Banksy
ruining people's dreams since since
and he didn't even go for that long
hey you would have been a far better boy
you'd still be there giving it every day
I'd be still there
okay next one what do they call them the
body is it Jake Allison yeah
now we just had a bit of a running joke
back in under 19s I was as understudy as
a number eight slash hooker so they
under 19s picked me as a number eight
that wanted me to play hooker and uh
Wellington players being Wellington
and you know like to have a bit of a
shirt off
um except me because I didn't have a
regular board so yeah
you'd keep yourself up I thought uh yeah
keep my top on
I I had an all right top half it was
just this uh mid-drift
not the greatest
so yeah got the nickname the body oh
like it okay next one uh this is our
question from a major sponsor swish go
and get yourself a swish if you're still
listening to this podcast but if you
could get a video shout out from any
celebrity who would Joe Royal choose
that's a good question
yeah I'd I'd be Keen to get videos I'd
like one of Tom Brady oh yeah
the gate
yeah no he'd be good
all right he's one of those guys where
age doesn't matter what is he like 40
and he's still playing
like top level NFL so
we've got three years left him yet
three oh mate see it I still got three
years playing I'm only 37. okay rang up
Anzac after gay let him know
all right I'm the I'm the I'm the New
Zealand version of Tom Brady come on
give me a gig
like that one though Tom Brady
absolutely okay next one tell us about
your first Tuatara experience so
is a stiny classic
and uh purple iguana do you know what
those are yeah well you know what the
purple cheese so you apparently you
meant to just
mix it in a like mix a little bit in a
cup and Skillet
um but I was handed you know I was
handed the two bottles and I was like
looked at them going well there's only
one way to do this and I gave it a The
Walrus holy yeah yeah
let's just say it's not a it's not a
drink that you'd want to do on a regular
yeah what was the afternoon oh I didn't
I actually I I was pretty good on it I
didn't I didn't uh spew anything but yes
it definitely hits you maybe a few
minutes later I was lucky I was I was on
my way home
it's not a not a drink that you want to
have on the regular yeah I could imagine
it doesn't sound too good anyway next
one who is the real TC you've trained
with
what is tasty ah
I don't know if you remember but you
know we had to get up and you had to
show those like your why at the canes oh
yeah I can't get up and say oh you know
I'd like to show him a photo like I
mistakenly got up and said
uh I'm hey Andre Royal I went to
territory College a School of Hard cuts
at school yeah school a school for hard
camps
the real the real TC that I've yeah that
I've trained with was old Johnny
I can see it my first uh experience
about a TC was in that cage yeah running
it super drill when I was in the wrong
wrong group
but yeah just
anyone that's just mental enough to run
at street is is a tcmi in my mind yeah
thanks a year like I said I stupidly
said that I was from a School of Hope
campus
and I got caught into what his office
and said he was like now that you've
said that you have to be a tough [ __ ]
now these boys are these boys will look
at you and be like back if you do
something soft they'll be like straight
onto you right away so like my mentality
of those trainings are like I've got to
be hard
oh yeah you don't want what you're
writing you're being self-dest he is
if you know me I'm not I'm not yeah I'm
not a
you know tough yeah I'm not
if you know what I mean not not tough
I'm not I'm a nice guy
doesn't want to be that
okay last question uh as always the best
piece of advice you have for a woodland
listener and I remember you saying at
the start of the episode that you sort
of wished you listened to some advice in
the earlier years of your career
I'm sure you've got some good ones for
us uh
I think it's the main one here like that
I'd like to get out it's just it's not
to not to give up like that's probably
the
the biggest have a bit of resilience
um it doesn't have to be in your footy
career just in life in general really
just yeah and when I go and speak to uh
like groups or or schools especially as
um yeah I just sort of remind them I
have this thing called the three p's
that I tell people and it's uh people
are potential people and perseverance so
if yeah if you can sort of align
yourself with um
uh good people recognize that you've got
potential in your resilience or you just
keep pushing you you know you're going
to make it regardless of what you're
doing yeah if you're a footy player a
netball player uh uh climbing the
corporate ladder trying to run a
business yeah
just just hang in there and you know
things will come love that is how do you
get that perseverance is there
is there a secret to it obviously you've
shown more than most ah
stubbornness sorry for me I reckon it's
just stubborn to say like
I I hate it when people tell tell me
that I can't do something yeah that's
that's a big motivator it's like
it's probably it's probably bad because
you know you're just trying to prove
people wrong if you keep doing that you
know you're not really
you know doing stuff for yourself you're
you're doing it for other people it's
work though
um yeah yeah it's worked
um yeah so
I've met for me I'm just like um
I'm just gonna keep proving people wrong
or or upset myself a a sort of a goal
and be like that's that's sort of uh
the goal that I want to get to so I'll
keep going until I get it and then once
I get there I'll be like [ __ ] we ask can
I go yes okay yeah love it mate I'm
gonna say that you you can't play for
Moana Pacifica this year
I love that I love it and like what a
podcast what an episode I knew it was a
journey that you'd had but Matt you've
been around you've seen some teams you
would have met some people along
um this beautiful game that we play
um and it's been a pleasure to sit down
and go through your journey with you but
thanks for coming on ah thanks to me and
that's been uh what was this episode 100
or a thousand
glad to finally make a you know you know
you made it when you've made the water
layer podcast you know it's uh you're
gonna take this podcast to the top no
doubt this will be the most downloaded
one of the year and um it'll be
inspiring many well yeah just thanks to
everyone that I've come across and admit
like you said met a lot of a lot of boys
playing and meet a lot of people and
I think without meeting you guys or
meeting everyone you know
again the journey wouldn't have been
as cool or
successful fun as it has been so yeah
thanks to everyone for for being part of
uh not just my life but my my family's
too because
um they're all sort of you're part of
our mining cows and our little fellow
uses whanau now so yeah that's it mate
you're a lad appreciate it
okay
[Applause]
[Music]